he was the man tasked with taking tough
decisions on Ukraine and that is what
general surovican delivered today in a
televised briefing with Russia's defense
minister
comrade defense minister having
comprehensively assessed the current
situation it is proposed to take up
defense along the Left Bank of the
danipa river I understand that this is a
very difficult decision but at the same
time we will preserve most importantly
the lives of our servicemen and in
general the combat effectiveness of the
troops
I agree with your conclusions and
suggestions for us the life and health
of Russian servicemen is always a
priority
means Russia is withdrawing from kerson
the only Regional Capital it managed to
capture since February the 24th the
Russian flag removed from Key buildings
checkpoints abandoned
this man tasked by Russia to help run
the place of reportedly killed today in
a car crash shortly after he recorded
this clip a Russian Retreat from kerasan
has been discussed here for a while and
it does allow Russian forces to take up
defensive positions on the Eastern side
of the river and sit tight there but it
also begs the question why Russia pushed
this far in the first place declaring it
forever Russian territory and within a
matter of weeks proving itself incapable
of holding it
the big man himself preoccupied it seems
with other things a tour of the hospital
a meeting with veterans
leaving the military mess to his
generals to take care of it
NATO Secretary General cautious in his
assessment Russia has absolutely lost
the momentum
they have been forced to give up a
territory but we should not
underestimate Russia they still have
capabilities they still have forces and
they also have forces and capabilities
that can strike Ukrainian cities
this is being spun on State tv as a way
of protecting Russian troops and
civilians but how many more would have
been saved if Russia had never gone in
in the first place